[Musique]
bonjour ami appelle rifostache à NASA
Blanco dicafrine donc mal les bénévoles
m'a toujours été bénévole et
actuellement on est dans l'association
Les Orchidées à la Ravine des Cabris
depuis une trentaine d'années
c'est association là c'est
une association personnes âgées
intergénérationnelle le plus jeune année
90 ans et le plus vieux né à 5 ans parce
que m'a trouvé il y avait quand même une
la justice quelque part par rapport à
nos aînés donc
occupe tout ce qui est culturel et
autres hautes à savoir accompagnement
l'entraide et la solidarité au niveau
des personnes âgées et la défense de la
culture réunionnaise
[Musique]
bienveillante parce que
les gens surtout les personnes âgées
dans tout leur démarche administrative
maladie parce que moi des personnes que
dans le cancer Parkins
et le mot le plus fort le respect sans
respect nous ça va nulle part c'est
comme un arbre sans racine sympa
donc il veut tout dire pour moi commence
depuis maintenant et puis ça va aller
très bien
[Musique]
avancer dans la vie si on connaît pas
à l'école diazote la Réunion c'est où
quoi comment français
mais qu'il est venu à la Réunion quoi
[Musique]
je m'appelle Alice Philibert ranurdzone
pèlerin
j'ai 61 ans je suis mariée j'ai deux
enfants et un petit fils
et je suis
médecin généraliste mais je suis aussi
[Musique]
c'est une nouvelle forme de médecine
centrée sur l'humain parce que je
considère qu'il y a deux parties dans la
maladie il y a une partie organique qui
concerne la médecine et il y a une
partie
qui concerne la personne qui concerne le
lien et le symbole et donc c'est une
démarche que j'ai mis au point à partir
de ma propre culture pour mettre chaque
personne au volant de sa vie de son
histoire et de sa santé elle s'appelle
zoothérapie en fait il s'agit que la
personne s'approprie sa capacité à
remettre en ordre ces émotions et son
histoire ses liens familiaux ces liens
sociaux parce qu'on est souvent malade
de son histoire
vous vous demandez je pense c'est la
persévérance quand j'ai une idée et
quand je mets un projet en route je me
dis qu'un projet s'est fait pour arriver
jusqu'au bout et donc je le mène
jusqu'au bout une autre c'est peut-être
d'être
authentique authentique c'est-à-dire que
je suis fidèle à ce que je me suis fixé
et je ne peux pas me renier une
contredire être dans la Corée
l'incohérence c'est compliqué
toutes nos épreuves se nous apportent
des leçons de vie et que un moment donné
elle s'accompagne souvent de souffrance
un moment donné il faut trouver cette
leçon de vie pour pouvoir lâcher la
souffrance et avancer vers d'autres
choses parce que notre vie est promise à
de très belles choses je me dis que la
terre et ma maison et les humains c'est
ma famille
donc voilà c'est terminé là
[Musique]
je m'appelle Colette dela j'ai 53 ans et
je suis consultante administrative
principalement dans le domaine foncier
[Musique]
aider les gens c'est ce que j'aime le
plus au monde voilà c'est ça fait partie
de mon caractère avec des valeurs de la
vie beaucoup de personnes se trouvent
confrontées à des situations difficiles
ils ne savent pas où s'orienter ils
savent pas vers qui elle est ils sont
totalement perdus toutes les personnes
qui sont dans un besoin foncier dans un
projet foncier
papa maman qui sont propriétaires qui
veulent faire des donations à leurs
enfants pas parents décédés donc drame
psychologique on est déstabilisé
désorienté on sait pas comment faire et
ben moi avec plaisir je souhaite
accompagner ces gens là dans ces moments
difficiles de la vie il y a déjà dans
les familles malheureusement très
souvent des conflits moi je suis là j'ai
aussi un rôle de médiatrice je construis
des ponts entre les gens
pourquoi engagement parce que quand vous
avez
vous lancez dans
l'histoire d'une famille quand vous
demandez à une famille qui s'approche de
vous et qui a besoin de vos services de
vos témoigner de la conscience se dire
c'est pas une petite affaire c'est
d'emblée créer un climat de confiance et
montrer à votre client que à travers ce
climat de confiance nous démarrons un
travail ensemble et nous irons jusqu'au
bout
[Musique]
que la population réunionnaise qui ne me
connaît pas encore puisse me solliciter
pour que j'ai les moyens d'aider encore
plus de gens je suis capable et j'en ai
envie
[Musique]
Pascaline Panama j'ai 44 ans je suis née
j'ai grandi à Saint-Benoît
aujourd'hui je suis donc directrice de
la Fédération meditrice c'est une jeune
structure qu'on a créé en 2017 pour
venir en aide aux acteurs qui
travaillent les filles végétales le
chocolat le vacqua la paille chouchou
bambou coco vétiver etc j'ai fait un
parcours littéraire donc dans ma
formation et puis j'ai découvert le
bénévolat associatif j'ai commencé
d'abord dans le développement de
quartier j'ai évolué dans
l'accompagnement socio-professionnel
donc des publics en difficulté et puis
j'ai voulu comprendre le milieu
économique parce que j'ai trouvé que le
milieu social était souvent déconnecté
du monde économique et je me suis
retrouvée à diriger une structure
d'accompagnement à la création
d'entreprise donc la couveuse pendant
une dizaine d'années je me suis fait
forcée en tout cas à essayer de créer
des passerelles entre le monde de
l'insertion et le monde économique donc
j'ai ensuite évolué en créant mon
entreprise dans l'ingénierie de projet
avec une spécialisation dans le champ de
l'économie sociale et solidaire puisque
c'est ça c'est mon mandat en fait je
n'ai pas compris en fait dans mon
parcours pourquoi on avait autant de
monde qui galérait pour pouvoir l'emploi
alors de l'autre côté il y aurait des
activités à développer et qu'on ne sait
pas le faire
quand je suis confronté à des cas
d'injustice que ce soit pour moi ou pour
les autres où j'ai tendance à réagir
c'est ce qui a aussi motivé mon
application dans le milieu associatif en
tant que bénévole en tant que militant
on dit de moi aussi que je suis quand
même quelqu'un d'assez persévérant donc
je ne lâche pas souvent la faire quand
voilà quand j'ai une idée en tête c'est
ce qui me permet aussi de contribuer
efficacement à développer des projets
[Musique]
notre enjeu dans notre filière des
fibres végétales c'est de changer le
regard du réunionnais sur ce patrimoine
que les gens arrêtent de rester seul
dans leur coin si nous sommes nombreux
nous aurons une écoute peut-être plus
attentive de la part des collectivités
des institutions
en tout cas nous l'espérons
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes Je me présente Gabriel
Florian je suis bénévole dans le comité
des chômeurs du port je ciel à la
commission des affaires sociales du CCAS
aussi voilà
[Musique]
j'étais ancienne de professeur des
écoles je suis en retraite et donc
ensuite j'ai voulu m'investir dans une
cause utile donc s'occuper des sans-abri
des gens les plus démunis et cela depuis
18 ans on est à peu près une quinzaine
et 9h et après à 11h il y a le repas le
repas est offert par la mairie il reste
à peu près 20 minutes et après il
ressortent on va les faire rentrer par
vous je participe aussi à la préparation
à la distribution de colis alors nous
recevons les vives avec les grandes
surfaces et aussi nous recevons aussi
pas mal de choses de la Banque
alimentaire des mascaren disons parce
que tous les jours on reçoit des fruits
ce sont les aventures voilà alors je
participe activement on veut pas de Noël
qui a lieu en décembre et donc c'est un
moment de partage et de convivialité
alors je suis désolé donc je vais me
rendre service aux gens autour de moi et
puis apporter aussi un peu de réconfort
peu d'entraide parce que je trouve que
il y a tellement de misères et tout bon
ben moi je ne suis pas grand chose mais
j'essaie d'apporter quand même avec les
conférence personne là pour moi chaque
personne a sa place dans la société
j'aimerais bien que d'autres personnes
rejoignent l'association et on aimerait
bien aussi avoir un travailleur social
qui ferait le suivi des sans-abri deux
groupes humains prend sa richesse dans
la communication l'entraide et la
solidarité visant à un but commun
l'épanouissement de chacun dans le
respect des différences Françoise Dolto
voilà et c'est tout
fondatrice de chances égales féministe
et fier de l'être je suis de formation
biologiste j'ai voyagé dans le monde
entier avec mes parents mon père est en
militaire et je suis arrivé à la Réunion
il y a 22 ans et là j'ai eu
l'opportunité on m'a proposé de
participer à une formation sur la
thématique de l'égalité femme homme j'ai
foncé parce que le thème j'ai adoré
pourquoi parce que c'était une valeur
que je portais forcément c'est une
thématique qui m'a toujours certainement
titillée sans être allé jusqu'à
m'impliquer et puis je suis profondément
convaincue que c'est une source
d'évolution de la société pour du
respect entre les femmes et les hommes
mais de toute façon du respect entre
tous et toutes la question de se pose
même plus pourquoi j'aurais fait ça
parce que ça m'a paru tellement évident
et tellement intéressant qui a 20 ans
parler de l'égalité femme homme j'étais
prise pour une extraterrestre je pense
que proposer des interventions de la
formation sur ce thème c'était un peu un
peu bizarre un peu délirant on va dire
ou alors c'est fini c'est un combat
terminé et bien sûr ça commence par les
jeunes comme comme toujours depuis
l'école primaire jusqu'à l'université
les formations auprès des jeunes mais
c'est aussi depuis quelques années un
travail qui se fait auprès des
entreprises entreprise privée entreprise
fonction publique pour la faire en sorte
que l'égalité professionnelle soit
réelle on a pu constater que cette
association n'a pas d'équivalent au
niveau national ça veut pas dire que ces
choses-là ne sont pas faites au niveau
national mais elles sont divisées je
dirais mais une structure qui balaye un
petit peu tous les champs c'est moins
fréquent et je ne connais pas
d'équivalent au niveau national un des
facteurs principaux de l'égalité en tout
cas professionnel c'est la mixité des
métiers la mixité professionnelle j'ai
vraiment le sentiment qu'on a participé
à ce changement en ce qui me concerne et
bien je vais passer le relais il est
temps de passer le relais aux jeunes
générations qui vont voir autrement et
différemment proposer des choses
différentes donc j'espère que les jeunes
Réunionnais réunionnaises ont envie de
reprendre le flambeau et de continuer
même si l'objectif de l'association est
de disparaître et de disparaître dans la
bonne humeur et la joie mais je serai
toujours là pour les aider bien entendu
parce que je pourrais quand même pas
lâcher complètement tout
[Musique]